it's interesting to
consider that we have
materially secured our needs as a
collective Society in ways that
would leave our ancestors astounded we
live with a level of abundance that is
that might have been inconceivable to
those that came before we live in a
world of riches we enjoy a level of
material comfort that is
unfathomable and yet we're learning very
quickly that securing our material needs
is simply not enough we are creatures of
mind and meaning we are creatures of
story we are creatures sustained not
just by food and shelter but by
narrative but by self story but by
Collective story and so as our our self
stories and our Collective stories
fracture underneath our feet we're
feeling increasingly a drift we're
feeling increasingly lost we're feeling
increasingly like we're losing our marbl
and we are losing our Marbles and the
material Comforts simply are not enough
I'm talking about the Mental Health
crisis that has really characterized
this moment in the 21st century
according to the World Health
Organization more people die by Suicide
than die from natural disasters and
armed conflict combined so people are
taking their own lives in numbers
greater than what we're seeing in war
zone so the real existential danger for
the average individual in the western
world is his own mind and the tools that
we have been using the tools we have
been deploying to sustain
this 21st century normal as Jamie wheel
calls it is simply sickening us even
more Psychiatry isn't working
Psychotherapy needs to be upended enter
psychedelics the Psychedelic revolution
in some ways is a return to a more
animistic understanding of self and
world uh kind of more intuitive and
shamanic and maybe call it spiritual
intuition about how to amend the issues
of our inner life in some sense the
reason man has used psychedelics for
thousands of years ceremoniously is
because these compounds provide a
different kind of psychotherapy one that
addresses not just our material needs
but the needs of our psyche and so there
is a return modernity is finally
catching up to Antiquity and there is a
return to this kind of wisdom we're
seeing clinical trials studying the
effects of psychedelics in ways that are
addressing the storytelling crisis that
is fracturing our inner Collective life
and people are healing from anxiety from
depression from PTSD from OCD from the
entropic brain from the over rumination
that characterizes all of these
pathologies of mind we're healing them
all together in a whole new way that can
scale this is the Psychedelic Revolution
and there's a lot of players in this
space there's a lot of people trying to
change the world by implementing new
scaffoldings building new infrastructure
where we can attract
the spiritual crisis of our time using
psychedelics and using science right
coupling those worlds together using
that indigenous wisdom and intuition and
scaling it using the tools of
infrastructure and potentially even
capitalism at its best it's a revolution
of the mind that could potentially allow
us to finally uplevel ourselves in a
whole new way as Jamie wheel famously
said maybe we can render ourselves whole
and then maybe we can render ourselves
holy or as Houston Smith said maybe we
can turn those passing illuminations
those moments of understanding into
abiding light we can finally turn
ourselves into something that can
heal and it's an important thing friends
the very future of our species says that
this is
so and
uh I guess the question is really
whether
[Music]
we're willing to step up to the plate
together to put our
resources to deliberately work together
come together deploy the tools the
resources at the scale that can address
this crisis in a way that can help
everyone cuz if
not what a [__]
shame let's do this friends
let's do this
[Music]
together